when your back is against the ropes and
you have everything to prove sometimes
you just gotta go super saiyan chronicle
playing behind the smoke and there's the
opening as they come around the corners
the moments where the impossible becomes
possible and players careers are defined
these are the moments that defined a
generation so today we are counting down
the top 10 super saiyan moments in
esports
starting off our list is the nifty 50.
nifty locking down the ct angle hasn't
spotted anyone out just yet but oscar
will go down nifty again
in the quarterfinals of iem sydney 2018
renegades were down a game against
mousesports but even though things
looked bad nifty wasn't about to let
mouse run away with the game in front of
his home crowd i
won't let you
get away with this
nifty found his super saiyan
transformation in the second half and
lit up mouse sports dropping an
unprecedented 50 bomb to clutch the map
that's a big kill for the renegades but
they need more nifty gets a connection
onto chris j and steps up against oscar
as well oh nifty he's bringing out the
goods in this
that's exactly what the renegades needed
let's see some more magic my friend with
that all chris jay goes down
and nifty is coming up absolutely insane
right now for the renegades
holy moly no one ever did it before and
no one will ever do it again nifty's
insane anime power-up is an iconic
moment in cs go history known forever as
the nifty 50.
coming in at number nine we have ignar's
leona pick at worlds 2017. leona in a
level one all in i mean it's insane
listen everyone always says
gets hit they're right on to him here
comes max lord two to get a piece of the
party he gets the chance to get in with
the shield 2017 was the height of
league's infamous ardent sensor meta
every support player had to pick
enchanters or they were basically
trolling but in misfits world's
quarterfinal match against skt ignore
decided to go with his gut not the meta
but i had intense moment with the
coaching staff after game on i was so
mad
i don't want to go home like this so i
want to show
our
team scholar misfits
so i say to hussein
you cannot do like this we should play
like us
game two i want to play my champion so
they're targeting more ignar as a player
rather than actually you know there's a
poor champion oh
my god the leo this makes so much sense
it seemed like a troll pick but with his
signature leona ignard went off the heel
comes out they turn to wolf his bank
feels like he can get back into the
fight just a hundred times
one more shot as wolf wants the glitter
lands
barrier comes in again
[Applause]
fighting the jungle still they can't go
what's going down
in
sadly misfits lost that series but they
pushed skt to five games and reminded us
to always trust our instincts not the
meta looking to be the first team ever
to accomplish what no team has done
before as they take skt to game point
can you believe it
in this game
taking the number eight spot on our list
is a performance so stunning it made
asuna the king of icebox tad too far
away to be able to isolate that despite
going down will be a heavy ring or
giveaway however the immediate pop of
the empress needs to be done for a
sooner now because he knows he's gonna
be potentially going up against both
players at once and he's right to assume
that but it doesn't even matter after
failing to qualify for masters reykjavik
asana and hundred thieves entered na
challengers stage 3 determined to prove
that they were a team that demanded
respect which is why during their very
first match of the tournament asana went
absolutely nuts on version one hundred
themes oh excuse me actually not having
the sage their apologies on my end just
i'm used to re-reading the hud again but
aside with a big triple kill with heroes
will take down vanity nitro with yet
another one and this is looking like the
first 100 thieves offense that's going
to go their way and it will in a gritty
36 round game on his best map icebox
asana powered up and dropped 48 frags to
help hundred thieves win the map 19 to
7. just to try and create some
separation between the two squads but
thief and version one moving quite
forward now asuna finds a nice frag with
the one way whippy with the refrag
though we back down to equal man count
as well no slowing down now and of
course it's a sunnah and asuna going a
full 48 kills apparently the single
largest kill total from a single map in
valor in history forget super saiyan
asana is icebox's king gold
get it
our number seven spot goes to perks's
11-0 game on leblanc and for the vast
majority of this ballpark so so close
the ignite is ticking that is nothing
perks is godlike
g2 were the underdogs at worlds 2018.
they had to fight through play-ins for
their spot in the group stage and had to
win a tie breaker to get into the
bracket but you can never count out an
underdog g2 took rng all the way to game
five but they were still staring down
elimination so perks put the team on his
back with his signature leblanc pick and
got to work defensive flash for moozy
teleport's coming
down blows up rng and the realm warp
will cut off that escape route but here
comes perks where in prison holds wonder
in place he will start to revive and
resurrect
just blows up mlxg wonder throws down
the infernal chains now why what did
well find a stand on to let me
this is chaos but it is chaos that is
benefiting g2 six zero and zero four
perks perks delivered a perfect 11-0
game annihilating rng with the single
best leblanc game of his career never
count out the underdogs the underdogs
reigns supreme at worlds 2018
when expectations were at their lowest
the g2 dynasty will be defined by taking
down rngs
coming in at number six is the play that
gave us a valorem god uh is tense he's
got the frenzy
and he's got a kill man
all up and moves his face and he's
getting a jumping one as well on the
thief i said this the first time i
called tens this is his world and we're
just living in it back at stage 1 and a
masters in 2021 sentinels needed a last
minute replacement player so they picked
up a good but still unproven weeby guy
named i don't know maybe you've heard of
him
tens dude there was like no time to uh
for like anything it was like super rush
but hey honestly
no practice might just work out the best
for us tomorrow will be the first time
i ever play with any of them in his
first ever set on sentinels and with
everything to prove tens popped off
against luminosity and cemented himself
as valrant's golden child right at the
beginning of the year it was in their
ability to take specifically against
sentinels but now that tens is in the
fold i don't know that you're gonna be
nearly as effective as you were before
the ace is stolen but it doesn't matter
you see sick is just kind of playing
around the flank making sure there's
nobody coming around the lyr comes
through tens once again good for another
one as everest continues to cause
problems that's three on the round he is
gonna drop at the hands of thief and now
it's on shazam with that op and of
course since then he's never stopped
being cracked on the sea take as we know
that titles are gonna have to play for
the reason but boys finds the greatest
time ever to backstab through window and
blindside dapper but tens and company
holding on but the response from cloud9
has been swift as well but since it's
gonna go all the way for the ace you
have to be kidding me
at the halfway point we have axes famous
for a stock so we'll find me down to his
last stop is he gonna get it before a
minute passes
whoa let's see he's right near the edge
oh my god
destruction
to stalking an opponent is hard in melee
it's not easy to take an extra stock
before an opponent gets one off you
three stalking someone is even harder
taking all four stocks without losing
one of your own that should be
impossible but axe the pikachu main
didn't let that stop him at evo 2014 up
against silent wolf and losers top eight
he went super saiyan and four stalk
silent wolf in less than a minute the
changing heights of the platforms can
really do a lot by messing him up
potential stock gets the up air tail
spike and suit
nice light shield not even trying to get
shield snap as the shields do get really
small another stock pikachu
the pikachu champ is humongous here
oh oh man silent wolf
we've seen a lot of four stocks on this
stage before but 45 seconds he's right
near the edge oh my god
destruction
[Applause]
next up at number four we have mango's
legendary losers bracket run at smash
summit 11.
was that the greatest set of
millionaires
for 20 years smash summit 11 didn't
start off well for mango after getting
knocked into the loser's bracket early
he was ready to give up but instead he
went on a rampage
what what was that circle that i saw
the melee gods descended for a moment
and said i need to show you something
you've never seen before melee community
i thought that was that against all odds
mango won five sets in a row against
some of the best players in the world
including hungrybox and plop before
facing off against zayn in the grand
finals
oh yo
yo he's cooking he's cooking
just listen to brandon
mango transcended his skills and played
a full 10 game set resetting the bracket
3-2 then barely beating zayn in the
reset with another 3-2 win manga went
from almost giving up to winning one of
the hardest tournaments of his career no
wonder it's one of melee's greatest
torment runs ever
oh god
oh the shield up
[Applause]
our bronze medal spot goes to seb's 11
million dollar berserkers call he gets
the goal
of his lifetime 60 minutes into a
grueling game four at ti-8 og overcame a
20k gold deficit and secured mega creeps
they just needed one more play to seal
the game unfortunately lgd got the upper
hand and the fight looked all but over
until seb blinked in from out of nowhere
to put the team on his back
look at the bad shout songs will be able
to fight the iron but they're fully low
ogd that song is there for two minutes
they get thompson thompson never do but
it's only anna anna can you do it here
he's at our best
[Applause]
managed to taunt all of lgd's heroes
giving his team enough space to wipe lgd
og went on to win that game game five
and 11 million dollars off the back of
this one heroic play
in second place we have stewie2k's
legendary 1v3
behold
it's no more prey
stewie's walking around we're going over
time
at the 2018 boston major any hopes of na
finally claiming their first major title
rested with cloud nine an underdog team
that barely got out of the group stage
and somehow made it all the way to the
grand finals at match point on inferno
in game three faze clan rotated late
onto b hoping to overwhelm stewie in a
1v3 but things didn't go as planned for
phase the molotov comes in but so does
the rotation olofmeister though has been
taken out towards the b bombsite but
also automatics going towards saying
nothing else is going on he's got to go
back stewie's on his own but look at the
time look at the time there's seven
seconds bomb they're trying to build
pyramids but there's no more play
stewie's around we're going over time
with the dreams of na on his shoulders
stewie pulled off an insane 1v3 clutch
that forced overtime where cloud9 won it
all
in our gold medal spot we have esports's
original super saiyan play evomomen37
[Applause]
if you haven't heard of this legendary
moment before it starts with daigo
facing off against justin wong in the
losers semi-finals of evo 2004's street
fighter 3 third strike tournament justin
knew that daigo couldn't get hit by or
block his next super the only way out
was to parry every single hit and he
figured that there was no way a mere
human could pull that off but daigo
wasn't human he parried every single hit
with perfect timing in that moment he
became the first esports super saiyan
and evo moment 37 became the most iconic
moment in esports history
[Music]
[Applause]
all right folks that's our list if you
think we missed a super saiyan moment in
esports let us know down in the comment
section below take care and i'll see you
in the next one
what's going on